For the
first time, scientists have disc
evidence of phosphorus in an oce
not on earth.
A new study
in the Journal of Nature
says the Life-Sustaining element
was found inside
salty ice screens
shot into space by one of Saturn
Not only is phosphorus
vital to all life on Earth,
but its presence supports
the idea that there could be
an ocean capable of sustaining l
Beneath that moon's icy surface.
The coauthor of the study says,
The next step is clear.
We need to go back to see
if the habitable ocean
is actually inhabited.
And joining us
now is a man who needs no introd
to Bill Nye, the Science Guy.
Bill, what do you make of all th
The possibilities are kind
of extraordinary here. What do y
Well, so if you have
an ocean,
salty ocean for a few billion ye
maybe there is something alive.
And so so far, using the first u
the data collected
by the Cassini spacecraft,
everybody was pretty sure there'
hydrogen and oxygen. Sulfur.
But finding phosphorous.
Atomic number 15 is significant
because, you know, we say in mag
they say it's all done with mirr
You know, we say in biochemistry
it's all done with molecules.
So when it comes to us,
our DNA is held up.
The the edge of our DNA is phosp
And so phosphorus and sugar
make the so-called backbone
or the railings of the staircase
And then you've probably heard o
atrazine triphosphate.
That's the the battery.
That's the energizer of our cell
And so having phosphorus
is very important to us.
And all the other
living things that we know of
which are all on earth.
But I will tell you, sir,
if we were to find evidence of l
on another world, right,
it would change this world.
How so?
Everybody would feel
differently about being a living
Yeah, I expand on that
because I think you're
absolutely right about that.
I just I think the entire planet
our planet would just be mesmeri
if there were some images or,
you know,
if we were to find
some kind of sign of life on thi
on this moon,
some inset with dungeons of some
Yeah.
You know,
there's a layer of ice, a shell
And under that is this ocean.
And it's kept liquid by the grav
of set
by the mutual gravity
of Enceladus and Saturn
squeezing it
and keeps
it warm enough to be liquid
all these billions of years.
And you cannot help but wonder t
these two questions,
these two questions we all ask
where did we come from?
We're right.
How did life get started?
Whose idea was this?
I know
people are very sure of some thi
but fundamentally, scientificall
we don't know how life started.
And then you wonder if it starte
or could start somewhere else.
Are we alone?
And then
the other deep question is we ha
deoxyribonucleic acid,
or by the way, phosphorus
is what makes it acidic.
It's very important to its funct
So we have DNA.
Does another form of life
on another world have DNA?
Does DNA always get involved?
Is it always part of the equatio
And then furthermore, did
life start somewhere else
and end up here
because things
fall toward the sun
after there are impacts out ther
Are we descendants of of Encelad
That's quite a hypothesis.
But we investigate it. Everybody
For a tiny fraction
of the federal budget,
a tiny fraction of space agency
around the world
go to this kind of investigation
and it leads
to these extraordinary discoveri
Back to you.
Well, and I mean, if this were t
you know,
I mean,
if we were to find
some more evidence of this,
we would have to go.
And how would we
how would we go in and further c
what may be taking place there?
Do we have we even have.
So we haven't even figured out h
to Mars,
you know,
besides sending rovers
and that sort of thing.
Well, how would we figured this
when you started getting out?
I got to say,
we started getting out
as far as Jupiter, Saturn,
getting people out there
becomes fantastically complicate
I'm not saying it's impossible
to just takes some huge investme
But 2027.
We're planning
to launch the Dragonfly mission
to another one of Saturn's moons
which is equally intriguing.
This as far as first thing
is just this week.
But it just shows
you also the tremendous value
of these missions.
Cassini
flew its 2017
and it launched 12 years before
And these data are still being a
are still thinking deep thoughts
what the
what the instruments can tell us
about these other worlds.
And so everybody we're not
jumping on a rocket
to go to Saturn
but we are going to send
another spacecraft there
and this is the extraordinary
dragonfly Arctic copper Arctic
copter it's
going to fly around
in the Titanic atmosphere.
It's going to be amazing.
And once again
they say all the time it's just
the investment is just very, ver
And if you are watching in the U
you're a U.S. citizen or what ha
Massa is the best brand.
The United States has people eve
Respect. Yes.
And furthermore, there's another
that engaged,
just like
Cassini engages
space agencies and scientists
engineers and taxpayers around t
Yeah. Thank you.
Well, you're absolutely right, B
You've given us a lot to think a
What be dreaming about this moon
perhaps, and wondering
what what lies out there. Yes.
Phosphorus is
science fiction quickly becoming
science fact.
Bill Nye, the Science Guy,
thanks so much.
Great to talk to you. Appreciate
Thank you, sir. All right.